We dug the boat out of the mire
at the seashore in my hometown.
It was actually covered in sludge.
So we waited till the tide had taken
some of the sludge away
to dig the boat out.
Then we cleaned and disassembled it,
and eventually brought it to New York.
I wanted to expose the skeleton
the frame of the boat, which looked more like an artwork.
The story of borrowing the enemy's arrows is about borrowing the opponent's strength
to make oneself strong in a short time.
There was a very resourceful
general called Zhuge Liang.
He filled the boats with straw soldiers and sailed toward the enemy's camp.
Mistaking the boats with straw soldiers for a surprise attack
the enemy showered the decoys with volleys of arrows.
The boat is a very familiar object to me.
It is one of the earliest vehicles that helped humans understand their relationship with gravity.
However, when the body of the boat is full of arrows like feathers
it suddenly transforms into a bird and seems able to fly.